look um you know they're not competent
and i i blame the sacramental media for
allowing kamala harris as a woman and as
a black person to rise and win all of
these different offices simply because
of her identity she wasn't qualified she
doesn't have the capacity and i honestly
will will double down on that if you
look there's no possible way susan rice
and ron klain did not prepare her with a
good book
of of what to say and what to do and
what the policy was i don't think it was
a lack of preparation i think it is a
capacity issue that she doesn't
understand these issues
she's been allowed to rise to the top
without any vetting from the media
there's been no uh push until she got
into the presidential and then the
national media a little bit we're like
wait a minute you're not really ready
and so she imploded
so with all of that in mind
none of this happened for the four years
under the guy that you worked for and
everyone kept saying oh but trump is
putin's puppet and all of these things
and yet oddly putin made a move on
crimea when joe biden was vice president
and then he cooled it off for four years
and then made a move when biden was
president are any of these things
connected or am i a crazy conspiracy
theorist
i know you personally you're not crazy
uh but don't forget that we should also
put in there though that um putin moved
on george under under uh bush under
president bush um this is not a partisan
statement to say that
you've got to be able to put america
first and articulate
the responses of of the u.s government
and you know i i think that it's really
important to point out donald trump
yesterday i heard him say that he was
tired of joe biden talking about how
russia has nuclear power
and is a nuclear force and it sounds
like you know when you say that that
you're scared and president trump said
you know what joe biden should be saying
we
are a nuclear power and we know what to
do and that i think therein lies the
difference is that donald trump was no
uh
wimp
he wasn't anyone who just said you know
i want to bring troops home and avoid
war
he built up the defense department he
built up america's power
he used the power with soleimani he he
was really able to to show
uh an unpredictability when it came to
using america power america's power but
he has his criteria and this is i think
a really important point what is best
for the us
and i'll finish by saying you know the
state department needs to learn this
lesson because when you talk about
america first
and all of the great things about what
that means to be an america first
advocate
um it doesn't mean america alone
and there's a way to articulate america
first and i believe this passionately
that america first helps our allies and
others when america is out front trying
to
push forward democracy human rights the
rule of law guess what every economy
benefits we see that inflation is spiky
now economies are not doing well when
america puts itself first capitalism and
the rule of law thrive that brings up
every other country we should have state
department
ambassadors overseas who articulate why
an america first policy is good for them
there should be no apologies about this
it's better to have america first than
to allow russia or china to put
themselves first and i think what we've
seen from 16 years of merkel it's much
better for america first than to put
germany first
so who do you think biden is putting
first right now i mean we it seems like
a lifetime ago but literally only three
weeks ago right before this whole thing
started we had about a two week window
of every day where biden it sounded like
he was basically acting as putin's pr
guy he kept being like well he's
probably gonna go maybe he'll go these
are the 16 things we don't want him to
do here's a bunch of stuff he can do i
mean
what is our policy at this point
look um i don't want to get too
philosophical or or theoretical here but
the opposite of america first is
consensus especially consensus with the
europeans
and i spent eight years at the u.n and i
can tell you inside the security council
that anytime there's a policy or a
statement coming out of the security
council it's the lowest common
denominator of what 15 countries believe
and it's not putting america first
certainly not putting democracy human
rights uh the rule of law first and so
joe biden is trapped in official
washington uh ideas that he wants to be
loved by um the world he talks you know
i know all these world leaders he really
prioritizes the applause from the
globalists and so when you think about
it um he he really wants the europeans
to be pleased the reason he dropped the
sanctions on nordstrom 2 is because
merkel and the germans at the time asked
him to he maximized being with the
germans being with the europeans having
them love him look no further than the
iran deal
iran deal two
and and now we we see the europeans
saying wait a minute this deal we're
gonna have to put it on ice because it's
going south when the europeans
are saying we need to stop this process
and the biden team is not the one
calling it first we've got a big problem
when you're behind the europeans but
this is the policy now i can go through
you know each area of the world look at
venezuela policy now we're moving and
transitioning into engagement again
which already failed with the
venezuelans simply because there's a
bunch of latin countries that want us to
do that and joe biden is leaning in and
letting them determine that policy the
same thing in the balkans i worked very
hard on kosovo serbia we had four
economic agreements you know what the
policy is now
let the europeans lead on this issue and
you know this is the whole 1990s crowd
filled with ngos that love to write
white papers and tell rich people to
give them money to to think about these
issues but they're not making at all
do you think that these people without
getting too far into the philosophical
part then do you think that that we he
at least has competent people i mean
when when you listen to kamala harris
talk about this stuff you know ukraine
is small russia is big even tony blinken
i mean all of they they don't sound
competent to me putting aside that you
may have a philosophical disagreement
with them on on what u.s strengths
should be or something like that do they
strike you as competent people but a
friend in need is a friend indeed dave
uh and look um you know they're not
competent and i i blame the sacramental
media for allowing kamala harris as a
woman and as a black person to rise and
win all of these different offices
simply because of her identity she
wasn't qualified she doesn't have the
capacity and i honestly will will double
down on that if you look there's no
possible way susan rice and ron clayne
did not prepare her with a good book
of of what to say and what to do and
what the policy was i don't think it was
a lack of preparation i think it is a
capacity issue that she doesn't
understand these issues
she's been allowed to rise to the top
without any vetting from the media
there's been no uh push until she got
into the presidential and then the
national media a little bit we're like
wait a minute you're not really ready
and so she imploded but the sacramento
media allowed her just to you know
catapult and take over
i don't think she's qualified i think
anthony blinken should have been fired
after afghanistan
i don't understand why he's still around
he's totally weak wendy sherman the
deputy at the state department you know
her nickname is what do you want wendy
when she goes into negotiations she
gives away the store she did it in north
korea in iran with russia
i don't know how many times we're going
to put her forward she's the
terrible negotiator for the united
states
and then you know susan rice is behind
the scenes supposedly doing domestic
policy which she's not qualified for
but i think she's pulling the string of
of all of these other positions remember
susan rice when she was national
security advisor had two deputies at the
nsc one was avril haynes who runs the
intelligence program as dni
and the other was anthony blinken who's
now running the state department so
diplomacy and intelligence
all are really under susan rice they're
her deputies she chose them
and that just means obama is pulling the
strings you know there's this philosophy
and i think i agree with it
that uh barack obama couldn't be the far
left progressive that he really wanted
to be
because as a black man he was in he was
very nervous about being um you know
somebody who was in the middle and being
accepted by all the the polite sides and
i find that to be a phony um uh you know
kind of analysis
but nevertheless
he he wasn't as progressive as people uh
said that he was going to be
but now unleashed in this obama third
term with a puppet like biden i think
the reality is is that susan rice and
ron klein and everybody from the obama
administration is back into this biden
team that the obama third term is
unleashed and they really are just using
joe biden as a puppet and as an empty
suit to kind of let go and and really
try all these hard left progressive
ideas since it's imploding
i think uh they now have a good
scapegoat where they can say you know
joe mess it up and maybe they'll try to
adjust i see them a little bit trying to
adjust
but they're not getting it fast enough
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell